I'm gonna get behind the mythological references
made in this trailer in a second, but as a
fair disclaimer, I haven't read the book,
so if you have read it, or if you got to see
the film in theaters already, let me know
if I was on point at all in the comments.
First I want to point out the setting.
Based off of this billboard, they're in Northern
Sweden.
If you pause on this shot of the map you can
see that they're cutting through Sareks Nationalpark,
so let's investigate that area.
It was first inhabited by a group of hunter-gatherers
known as the Sami, who used these mountains
as places of worship.
One of the mountains was known as Mount Apar
and it was believed to house demons and the
ghost of an illegitimate child.
Remember that, because I'm gonna come back
to it.
But with that being said, let's approach the
rest of the trailer with Norse mythology and
Pagan culture in mind.
At the beginning of the trailer, the characters
put together a little ritual of their own
for their deceased friend, Rob.
In Nordic culture, they had a number of places
of worship in nature and their holy spaces
were often marked with some kind of landmark.
It could be anything from the base of a mountain
to an entire valley to a notable pile of rocks
as we see here.
Sacrifice rituals were a huge part of this
culture, especially in relation to births,
marriages and death.
And these rituals often involved the sacrifice
of food and drink and the consumption of alcohol.
It's possible that the ritual mentioned in
the title of the movie is this ritual; that
these four characters attempting to honor
their friend have actually awoken some malevolent
spirit from Norse mythology.
In fact, the people who settled on this land
believed in the ability to influence the living
from the land of the dead.
If the rituals were performed correctly they
could give their blessings and stuff, but
if done incorrectly, it was believed that
dead could haunt the living and bring bad
fortune.
I'd say both of those things are going on
in this trailer.
Before I move on, let me emphasize one thing.
I want you to imagine a Nordic celebration
in your head.
You're probably imagining a bunch of burly
dudes in viking helmets dancing around in
a circle with big frosty beer mugs in hand.
That may be a stereotype, but in reality the
consumption of alcohol was instrumental in
these rituals.
This one character does appear to have a drinking
problem, but perhaps the constant appearance
of these shelves of alcohol in dreams and
hallucinations is actually a sign of something
more.
If you go frame by frame, this is all over
the trailer.
That brings us to the first strange thing
they come across, which is this cow that is
hanged in the tree and gutted.
Sacrifice rituals known as blót were a huge
part of the traditions practiced in Northern
Sweden before the common era.
They would actually hold festivals in which
male animals corpses were hung in trees as
a sacrifice to their deities.
That included both wild animals found in the
area, and men.
It's quite possible that our main characters
have unknowingly walked into a ritual to honor
those Pagan Gods.
There's more evidence to back this up.
This guy they stumble upon seems to be praying
to some kind of altar.
These markings seen on the trees match up
with the ones on the pole in this shrine,
where we again see a praying figure.
The idol pictured here has goat-like horns
and stands up on two legs in a humanoid pose.
Similarly, the cow the they found hanging
in the tree was oriented in a way that that
made it appear to be standing on two legs
as well.
This is most likely a reference to Fylgja,
a mythological Norse spirit that can take
the form of ox, goat and boar, among other
animals and is said to mark the transformation
between human and animal.
Fylgja are said to appear during sleep and
seeing one is an omen of death.
It would appear that death is indeed in some
of these characters' futures just based off
of this trailer.
There are also flashes of that praying figure
cut into the trailer elsewhere, but upside
down.
That could possibly play into the whole hanging
motif, but we'll have to wait and see.
The creepiest part of the trailer for me was
this hand that one of the characters sees
wrapped around a tree in the forest.
If you take a closer look these are pretty
thin trees and the hand is actually very small.
Remember how I mentioned that the area was
thought to house demons and the ghost of an
illegitimate child?
I think this could be that child.
And one last thing, it seems like they find
shelter at some point, and on the shelf right
here, I spotted this hammer that resembles
Thor's Hammer, which is regarded as the most
important symbol in all of Norse Mythology.
Not only was it a weapon used to defend the
domain of the Gods, but it was also used in
formal declaration ceremonies to bless marriages,
births, and funerals, just like the sacrifice
rituals I mentioned earlier.
There's also an excellent song by Equilibrium
called Wingthor's Hammer, and on that note,
you'll have to take some of my deductions
in this video with a grain of salt, seeing
as how most of what I know about this culture
was learned from listening folk metal bands
like Equilibrium and Finntroll, but let me
know if this stuff made sense to you.
A lot of people are saying this is just another
Blair Witch type movie, but I'm hoping it
will make use of the extensive lineup of Nordic
mythological creatures, because some of them
are pretty cool.
If that's something you want to see, let me
know by leaving this video a like.
And if you're new here, I'm going to be covering
all the best horror films of 2018, as well
as making my own.
So if that's something you want to see, subscribe
to CZsWorld for new horrors every week, hammer
that deathbell for notifications and I'll
see you in the next one.
Assuming we both survive.